[Music]
can we watch this relationship advice
sure
okay let's let's get into this right now
is this kind of a reaction video and
i got married to my husband who lives in
america over zoom
even though i haven't met in person yet
she married her husband she met over
zoom they've never ever met in person
and they live in different countries
yeah i would assume he lives like in the
states she lives in uk somewhere
okay
i think we realized like pretty fast
that it was turning into something
more than just being friends
but how do they meet
uh
they're waiting for a visa to go through
oh okay
okay this feels like a
yeah
somebody has an ulterior
agenda yeah somebody's trying to get a
green card here yeah
i approached him
put on my
big girl pants
and uh i messaged him first i got his
information from his mum
and then what hold on let's just let
this develop i messaged him he messaged
me back and then and i just went from
there i think my first impressions were
that
it was
it was really weird because i remember
when we first
we first spoke on the phone
and i think we both kind of expected it
to be awkward because awkward like we'd
only really messaged each other and we'd
never heard each other's voices or spoke
but it was kind of like we'd
we'd already spoke to each other before
like we would it wasn't like it was the
first time that we spoke to each other
sounds like you got a pen pal
yeah
it sounds like you've been writing fan
fiction yeah for the last year this is
bizarre how did he how did she know his
mom that's what i want to know she's
like she's dancing around that part yeah
imagine meeting the guy from your fan
fiction yeah a year later yeah that's
got to be a cr pretty crazy feeling i
say fan fiction because they probably
write like hell of sex to each other
yeah yeah oh yeah you think they go off
in the zoom chat yeah are all of these
photos photoshopped oh yeah i guess they
would be well damn oh that's weird
bizarre all right let's just go let this
go i think we realized like pretty fast
that it was turning into something
more than just being friends um
i mean i think i mean well to be fair
because it was like
literally only a couple of weeks after
we first started talking where
we started we turned it into a
relationship not just friends
and so i think it was like it was it was
pretty it just it kind of naturally just
went into into that like
she has like
like a bootleg stuffed animal where they
like print someone's face how do you
take the next chapter or the next step
you know she was like
what did she just say in two weeks then
we made a relationship more than just
friends yeah
so what is it like did you send
then maybe nudes nudes or
you just kind of made like the you know
the boob the ascii boobies in the zoom
chat
yeah
that's how you take it like damn okay
they taste like that
just
[Laughter]
then he's silently on the other side he
pulls his penis out
and they just nod at each other yeah
it's like yeah this is we've taken the
next step
it's like some national geographic type
[ __ ] yeah where they they both back up
in front of the camera naked yeah take
off all their clothes and just stand
yeah what is it like what is zoom
sex like is there you know i know yeah
you can just jerk off on the screen
whatever like you can on facetime or
whatever but like zoom is such a
engaging app it's built for so much more
than that so yeah like you change your
background screen chair yeah could you
just background dude you could do a
whole role play yeah exactly you know
yeah that's true you could you could get
like two sides of a scene like one's a
bartender yeah yep hello it's my first
time in america show me your tits
babe i thought we were gonna be like a
little more subtle oh my bad my bad
it's okay what do your boobs look like i
hadn't even started yet sorry man get
back to the beginning all right hello
hello i'd like one
cold
bud light please
you ever had sex on the beach
i like the drink i've never had that
show me your tits okay what are you
doing later um i was gonna role play
with my girl on zoom
yeah we're doing uh
we're doing the dentist today you ever
like join a zoom when it's recording and
it's like zoom is
recording he's trying to be subtle about
it
this meeting is now being recorded hey i
thought i thought it was just gonna be
in the moment i just i don't know dude i
just wanted to you know for later
you would jerk off without me oh i guess
not cheating
is that zoom cheating is it zoom
cheating if i jack off to you later
honestly we're about it's fine we're
about to be in the metaverse dude all
dating is gonna be like this i mean
dating like this exists already like
people meet on world of warcraft and
then get engaged and yeah and that's
arguably less interactive than zoom
that's what i'm saying it's almost more
normal weirdly for people to get like
married through text yeah because it's
like then you're like so far gone it's
like whatever be happy yeah but for this
it's like it's so close to actually
knowing each other in person yeah but i
guess like
like for them to get married is [ __ ]
crazy it's like just wait until you can
see each other
yeah they're gonna open the borders
eventually like is this a visa thing no
i i think it's a can you imagine like
wanting to get on zoom with someone
that's a pretty good connection
yeah that's a good point to want to open
zoom in the first place that's a really
good like
i want to stare at you and talk forever
that's crazy yeah that's almost like
true love like i bet the quality of
their conversation is probably better
than most people on tinder yeah so
i think they did this right
i think they actually did this right
because
that's the hardest part of a
relationship when you strip away all the
things of like going out and
you know yeah true context they just
talk
if they really enjoy this sitting on
zoom with each other then like the rest
will be a breeze yeah yeah because then
they'll have [ __ ] to do yeah yeah so
that's crazy yeah yeah that's a good
point so [ __ ] this clickbait ass hating
ass article man match on tinder or
unhinge and they'd be like let's hop on
a zoom just send that's what you should
do that's what you should your should be
your opening line on tinder just send
them a zoom link yeah and wait
and just be in there just like
yeah with a suit on yeah and then they
join
hello this is your formal interview to
date me
hi hello hello hi can you see me hi
how are you great great so uh it says
here your name is
uh maddie cool
yeah my name is maddie good good stuff
so uh where you from
i'm from wisconsin okay cool wisconsin
go badgers
so tell me what your issues yeah go
badgers
oh i'm sorry we're delayed
so are you going there you go you go
oh
you're very pretty
[Laughter]
i wasn't gonna say oh so thank you thank
you
thank you
why did you send the boobs emoji in the
chat
babe last night you reacted to my
to my boobs with the hundred emoji
i just wanted to know what you meant by
that i just felt like you were being
real with me
buddha you know i hate when you put the
hundred emoji on my tits
stop
damn that's funny i wonder if people
actually do that respond to nudes with
just like the reaction the reactions and
imessage dude yeah if i if i was single
just the exclamation marks thumbs up
like wait what is that good or bad to
respond with ha ha yeah yeah